today we are here to announce a major
gift to Carnegie Mellon University at 35
million dollar gift from Tata
Consultancy Services it's a historic
moment for a variety of reasons it's the
largest gift from a corporation from
largest corporate gift in the history of
Carnegie Mellon University it's the
largest gift from outside the united
states in the 115 year history of
Carnegie Mellon University it's the
largest gift by TCS to date to any
university and it's the fifth largest
gift in the history of Carnegie Mellon
University it will become part and
parcel of what we call a corridor where
innovation and creativity along Forbes
Avenue will flourish it's a great
pleasure and privilege to share this
afternoon with all of you Carnegie
Mellon is known for the best of
Education best of research the
researchers here the institution will
give a great opportunity for TCS
researchers to do some joint programs we
will bring a lot of industry problems
and in the future we will have you look
to see some CMU graduates under
graduates joining TCS s the place to be
it's a very very powerful statement
about philanthropy support of higher
education in a borderless world where
there is a relentless competition for
talent whether you are running a
university whether you are running a
global company you want to find the best
and the brightest people to do
cutting-edge things and this is an
expression of an engagement by a major
global company in
engaging with the University